[Music]
as the world faces down the coronavirus
infectious disease experts are becoming
central to our lives
advising world leaders and us on how to
survive
but these scientists aren't just
battling a virus while under heavy media
scrutiny
they're also fighting misinformation
politicized messaging
and even personal attacks
their research information and advice is
becoming even more critical
as more variants emerge with unknown
mutations
scientists are often happy to be behind
the scenes working on experiments and
trials hoping to produce a success that
may end up in an academic journal one
day but the pandemic has catapulted this
next woman
from the lab into the spotlight like
many of her scientific
peers a microbiologist and virologist at
the university of costa rica
and joins us now how does it feel to
suddenly be
at the center of government decision
making
well it's a difficult task because as
you said
scientists tend to be in the lab and do
experiments and trying to have like a
introverted life and because of this
pandemic we have to jump
in and trying to give advice and try to
give
our um show what we know and what we can
prove or not prove or have evidence for
it so it has been a
difficult thing to do playing that
advisory role how much time does that
leave you then in the lab
well that's a good question actually
uh before coronavirus i used to work
with dengue and zika virus with arbor
viruses
and i have a lot of ongoing projects and
i also teach i mean i'm a professor
so it's um difficult uh to manage
all the time to in order to
read and learn everything from this new
virus
to see all the this tsunami of
information that is coming
from all the scientists all around the
world and
uh to really have time for other things
actually my life right now it's like
80 percent of my day time it's
coronavirus and
like 20 is teaching so i i have
neglected
all other things it feels like that for
a lot of us
uh to tell you the truth um tell me
though how
how much influence do you really have as
an advisor how much of
all of that information that you get
gets through to the politician
well that's a a really good question
because
we science advisors have to learn that
we have just to present
the data to repres to present evidence
it and to
uh suggest things but at the end we are
not the ones taking the decisions
we're just there trying to the
politician to make
a better or the best decision that he or
she can make
so it's kind of a difficult thing for
example for me it has been really
um i have a lot of of influence for
example in diagnostics or
or how we handle the disease or how we
understand the virus or what's happening
with all these new variants as you said
before
but um the the actual measures like for
example lockdown or economical
consequence having economical
consequences
it's part of what the politician should
do so i'm not
that powerful but um i think
that for at least here in costa rica the
government has been really good
opening for us the scientists this
slot so that we can go through and
suggest
what about the message of masks then
some scientists reportedly
played that down to prevent a mass
public rush on masks and ensure supplies
to medical staff what went wrong there
well i think we were naive actually all
of us that
used to study coronaviruses before we
were
um we knew about coronavirus sars
one and we knew that we it we were able
to control it so when
all the cases were starting to come up
in china
we thought that maybe well this is this
looks like stars
maybe it's something similar maybe we
can control it
in the same measures that we used
in 2002 and 2003 and i think we were
kind of hoping and naive that
thinking that it was going to be like
tsar's one but we were surprised
actually
we we we knew
at that moment after wuhan went into
lockdown and after china went into
lockdown
that it was going to be um quite a
difficult
time and um and i think that scientists
were
kind of uh biased thinking that the
pandemic was gonna be another virus like
for example an influenza virus we were
actually
some of us were thinking about the
coronavirus and and they were there
but we were not that um sure and i think
it was a problem and
the the who also was a little bit slow
trying to to declare this an emergency
and to
to prevent we're also seeing the same
problem with the vaccine a a lot of
people are saying it's not a hundred
percent but we know
95 is fantastic it's one of the best
vaccines we've ever had
it's it's the best vaccine that we ever
had the problem is that these
respiratory viruses so the vaccine
probably is not that
a 100 effective preventing infection
but it's good preventing disease
severity hospitalizations
and dying so it's a great vaccine
actually it's kind of
you have to wonder of this achievement
of this scientific achievement that was
so good and so fast
uh and so effective actually i think
it's a lot of misinformation and
and social and science social social
networks that start to have this kind of
of conspiracy theories and all this
stuff that it's kind of
affecting how uh scientists uh
show what's going on and and and
explain what's going on okay we'll have
to leave it there
here thank you very much for being on
the show today
thank you for having me venezuela is
battling surging coronavirus cases on
top of a
drawn out economic crisis the lockdown's
forcing thousands of people to pack up
and leave which is complicating the
situation for colombia
carlos duque watches the moment when
amidst cheering
he left the hospital he's colombian
and spent 36 days in intensive care
there he saw the havoc that covid19 has
caused in the hospitals of cucuta
in general the attention of the doctors
and nurses was very good
but i also saw that there are a lot of
people who are left on their own
abandoned you get there and you are
practically left in a disposable diaper
connected to a machine
in an effort to curb the spread of the
virus authorities close the colombian
venezuelan border
but that has not stopped the flow of
people non-governmental organizations
estimate that some 100 000 people
continue to move between the two
countries
every day they do it along illegal
trails like this one
where the authorities are too
overwhelmed to carry out
any health checks it puts more pressure
on city hospitals
some of them have reported a 100 percent
bed occupancy
and crosses it using these illegal
trails ends up being a spreader of the
virus to everyone around him
and the number of people he can infect
is really impossible to calculate
coronavirus safety measures are barely
respected in kukata
many do not maintain social distancing
or even wear a mask
even without the illegal border
crossings epidemiologists
fear that a second wave could soon hit
the region
that could bring the already alarming
death toll in the border areas
to new highs and it's that part of the
show where our science correspondent
derek williams tackles your questions
on the coronavirus
which vaccine is currently the safest
and most effective one
around 10 different vaccines are
currently being given on a pretty
wide scale to people in various
countries around the world but some
still haven't completed trials or
published all their data
it would be irresponsible at this point
to recommend
one over others but i'm happy to take a
closer look at the two so far
that have checked all of the boxes for
emergency authorization
in the eu um both are what are called
messenger rna vaccines and they're the
first
ever based on this technology platform
to be approved one was co-developed by
german biotech company biontech
and and pharma giant pfizer um the
second
comes from a u.s based biotech company
called
moderna now let's look at safety first
both vaccines were tested in trials
involving over
30 000 subjects half received the
vaccine the other half were given
a placebo some of the people who got the
candidate vaccines
reported mild issues especially after
the second dose like like headache or
fatigue
or pain at the injection site but those
usually passed quickly with with no
major adverse events reported
since they've been rolled out a few
dozen recipients have had
more serious allergic reactions to them
what's called
anaphylaxis but don't forget the two
vaccines have now been administered
to tens of millions of people
some deaths in fragile seniors in norway
who received the pfizer biontech vaccine
are also currently
being investigated and and
recommendations in the future
might also change for that small group
but as of now both candidates have lived
up to expectations
that they would be very safe to take um
possible long-term effects will only be
revealed in time of course
but there's no sign of any so far when
it comes to effectiveness
trials showed the two pretty much neck
and neck
on both the modeona and the pfizer
biontech
vaccines prevented the development of
covid19 symptoms and around
95 percent of the people who received
both doses
which is an absolutely top-notch result
and we leave you with some advice from
the terminator the legendary cyborg
hollywood star and former california
governor arnold schwarzenegger
was given the jab at the dodgers stadium
drive-through site in los angeles
all right i just got my vaccine and
i will recommend it to anyone and
everyone
come with me if you want to live